i'll try not to be emotional about this
but i
heard
uh
anthony fauci
a couple of times now say that he
represents
science i know what he means by that he
means in this political bickering
all that kind of stuff that
for a lot of people he represents
science
but words matter and this isn't just
clips i mean maybe i'm distinctly aware
of that doing this podcast like yeah i
talked for like hundreds of hours now
maybe over a thousand hours
but like
i'm still careful with the words
like i'm trying not to be an and
i'm aware when i'm an and i'll
apologize for it
uh like if the words i represent science
left my mouth which they very well could
i would sure as hell be apologizing for
it
not enough because i got in trouble i
would just feel bad about saying
something like that and even that little
phrase i represent science
no dr fauci you do not represent science
i love science the the millions of
scientists that inspired me to get into
it
to fall in love with the scientific
method in the
um
exploration of ideas through the rigor
of science that anthony foshee does not
represent he's one i believe great
scientist
of millions
he does not represent anybody uh he's
just one scientist and i think the
greatness of a scientist is best
exemplified in humility
because the scientific method basically
says
like you're you're like standing before
the fog the mystery of it all
and like slowly chipping away at the
mystery and the it's like it's
embarrassing it's uh humiliating how
little you know that's the experience so
the the great scientists have to have
humility to me and especially in their
communication they have to have humility
and i mean i don't know and some of it
is also words matter because
you have to like great leaders have to
have the poetry of action they have to
be bold
and inspire action across millions of
people
but
you also have to
uh
through that poetry of words
express
the complexity of the uncertainty you're
operating under be humble in the face of
not being able to predict the future or
understand the past or really know
what's the right thing to do but we have
to do something and through that you
have to
be a great leader that inspires action
and some of that is just words and he
chose words poorly i i mean i so i
i'm all torn about this and then there's
politicians they're taking those words
and
magnifying them and playing games with
them and of course
that's the disincentive for the people
who do
the the scientific leaders that step
into the limelight
to say any more awards so they kind of
become more conservative with the the
words they use i mean it just becomes a
giant mess but i think the solution
is to ignore all of that
and to be transparent to be honest to be
vulnerable
and uh
to express the full uncertainty
of what you are operating under to
present all the possible actions and to
be honest about the mistakes they made
in the past i mean there's something
even if you're not directly responsible
for those mistakes
taking responsibility for them
is uh is a way to win people over like i
don't think leaders realize this often
in in the modern age in the internet age
they can see through your and
it's really inspiring when you take
ownership so to do the thought
experiment
like in public do a thought experiment
if there was a lab leak and then lay out
all the funding the equal health
alliance
all the
incredible science going on at the uh
wuhan institute of virology and the nih
lay out all the possible ethical
problems lay out all the possible um
mistakes that could have been made and
say like
this could have happened and if this
happened here's the best way to respond
to it and to prevent it in the future
and just laid all that complexity out i
mean i wish we would have uh
seen that and i have hoped that
this conversation conversations like it
your work
uh and a books on this topic will
inspire young people today when they
become in the anthony fauci's role
to be much more transparent and much
more humble and all those kinds of
things that this is just a relic of the
past when there's a person no offense to
me in a suit that has to stand up and
speak
with clarity and certainty i mean that's
just the relic of the past this uh
my hope but
do you mind if i have mag i agree
with a great deal of of what you said
and i and i it's really unfortunate uh
that our certainly the chinese
government as i said before our
government
wasn't as transparent as i feel they
should have been particularly in the
early days of the pandemic and
particularly with regard to the issue of
pandemic origins i mean we know that dr
fauci was on calls with people like
christian anderson at scripps and others
in those early days raising questions is
this an engineered
virus there were a lot of questions
and it's kind of sad i mean as i
mentioned before i've i've been um one i
mean and certainly there were others but
there weren't a lot of us
of the people who from the earliest days
of the pandemic
were raising
questions about hey not so fast um here
and i and i launched my website on
pandemic origins in april of last year
april 2020 it got a huge amount of
attention and actually my friend matt
pottinger who was the deputy national
security advisor when he was reaching
out to people
in the u.s government
and in allied government saying hey we
should look into this the what he was
sending them was my website it wasn't
some u.s government information
and so by the way people should still go
to the website
you keep getting keep updating it and
it's it's an incredible resource thank
you thank you jamie metzel.com
and it's really unfortunate that our
governments and international
institutions for pretty much all of 2020
weren't doing their jobs
of really probing this issue people were
hiding behind this kind of false
consensus and and i'm critical of many
people even when i heard uh francis
collins uh interview with you i just
felt well he wasn't as balanced on the
issue of of covet origins certainly dr
fauci um could have in his conversation
with rand paul it wasn't even a
conversation but in some process and the
aftermath
could have laid things out a bit better
he did say and francis collins did say
that we don't know the origins and that
was a shift um uh and we need to have an
investigation so now
um but having said all of that
i do kind of
one i have tremendous respect for dr
fauci for the work that he's done on hiv
aids i mean i have been vaccinated with
the moderna vaccine
dr fauci was a big part of the story of
getting us these vaccines that have
saved
millions and millions of of lives and so
i i don't think i mean there's a lot to
this story
and then the second thing is it's really
hard
to be a public health expert because you
have your mission is public health and
so and you have to if you are leading
with all of your uncertainty
it's a really hard
way to do things and so like even now
like if i go to cvs and i and i get a
tylenol somebody has done a calculation
of how many people um will die from
taking tylenol and they say well we can
live with that
and that's why we have regulation and so
all of us are doing kind of summaries
and then we have people in public health
who are saying wow we've summed it all
up and you should do x you should get
your kids
vaccinated for
measles um you should not drive your car
at 100 miles an hour you you should
don't drink lighter fluid whatever these
these things are and we want them to
kind of give us broad guidelines
and yet now
our information world is so fragmented
that if you if you're not being honest
about something that's something
material
someone's going to find out and it's
going to undermine your credibility and
so i agree with you
that
that there's a greater requirement for
transparency now
maybe there always has been but there's
an even greater
requirement
for it now because
people want to trust that you're
speaking honestly and that you're saying
well here's what i know
and this is based on what i know here
are the conclusions that i draw
but if it's just and again i i don't i
don't think the words i'm science or
whatever it was are are the right words
but if it's just you know trust me
because of who i am
i don't think that that flies anywhere
anymore
you